la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue christophe béchu pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre du budget
en sa qualité de ministre de tutelle du
service des douanes des attentats
tragiques qui ont frappé si durement
notre pays ont éclipsé médiatiquement un
drame le 23 novembre dernier qui s'est
déroulé à toulon et qui s'est traduit
par la mort en service commandé d'un
douanier appartenant la direction
nationale de la recherche et des
enquêtes douanières à douaniers qualifié
par ses collègues d'agents exceptionnel
un douanier qui laisse une famille qui
avait 42 ans et auquel je voulais cet
après midi que nous puissions rendre
hommage après le tumulte des élections
et de tout le reste
il s'appelait pascal robinson
à travers lui et à travers ce deuil ce
drame qui a frappé l'ensemble de la
famille des douaniers c'est aussi
l'occasion d'évoquer les conditions
compliquées difficiles de travail des
agents des douanes en insistant sur le
fait que depuis dix ans les douaniers
ont perdu en moyenne un poste par jour
on sait que leur niveau d'équipement
sont désuets qui doivent se débrouiller
que la lutte contre les go fast en
particulier se fait avec des véhicules
qui n'ont pas la puissance en terme de
cylindrée qui correspond à leurs besoins
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est simple
quels moyens le gouvernement entend
consacrer pour assurer et pour renforcer
les moyens qui sont mis à la disposition
de ces hommes et ces femmes qui assurent
notre sécurité et qui mérite notre
respect et notre connaissance pour vous
répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur 15 meur sur le sénateur je
m'associe à l'hommage que vous venez de
rendre aux douaniers qui avec les
policiers les gendarmes tous ceux qui
portent l'uniforme dans un contexte
particulièrement difficile qui incarne
l'état de droit qui incarne l'ordre
républicain paie un lourd tribut pour
assurer la sécurité des français et pour
sauver la vie des autres et le douanier
robinson dont vous avez rappelé la
mémoire et l'action a été un remarquable
douaniers il est tombé le 23 novembre
dans le cadre d'une opération de lutte
contre le crime organisé il est tombé
avec courage et le courage était sa
boussole puisqu'il avait déjà déjà
distingué en 2009 il avait reçu la
médaille de la défense nationale pour
des faits qui avait déjà témoigné de son
exceptionnelle équation personnelle de
sa personnalité qui était à la fois
généreuse et pleine de bravoure et tous
ses camarades sont dans le deuil toute
la famille des douanes et dans le deuil
je voudrais
et m'associer à vos propos qui étaient
d'une grande sobriété d'une belle
profondeur et qu'on doit à toutes ces
femmes à toutes ces sommes tous ces
hommes qui tombent pour assurer la
sécurité des français
vous dites qu'il faut des moyens
supplémentaires pour les douaniers vous
avez raison parce que les effectifs ont
été rodé qu'il faut leur donner des
moyens de fonctionnement c'est la raison
pour laquelle en même temps qu'ont
annoncé une augmentation des moyens pour
la police et la gendarmerie il a été
décidé d'augmenter 2000 les effectifs de
douaniers pour assurer un bon contrôle
aux frontières il participe très
largement au contrôle aux frontières
depuis le 13 novembre mais pour leur
permettre aussi de jouer le rôle
remarquable qui est le leur dans la
lutte contre le crime organisé ça doit
se traduire aussi par des moyens
supplémentaires en fonctionnement parce
que rien ne sert de recruter des
douaniers s'ils n'ont pas les moyens de
fonctionner il y aura donc trois
millions d'euros pour les doter en
moyenne fonctionnement ses mille
douaniers en véhiculant moyens
numériques en moyens informatiques et
piles y aura 26 millions d'euros qui
seront investis pour permettre à ces
douaniers de se protéger les événements
qui se sont passés tragiques auxquels où
la loire conclut au monde qu'il faut des
gilets montrent qu'il faut des moyens de
protection n'est le gouvernement sur la
base des arbitrages rendus par le
premier ce ne lésinera pas et les moyens
seront là pour les douaniers qui remplit
des missions difficiles
merci monsieur béchu vous vouliez